Some people don't recognize how important Nigeria is.
In sub-Saharan Africa, almost a quarter of the people live in one country.
I'm here with my friend, Aliko Dangote.
A lot of people, they're not really aware of the malnutrition issues that we have in Nigeria.
Malnutrition is such a gigantic problem.
Part of it is just getting enough food,...
...but another part is getting various vitamins, micronutrients.
You really want a supplementation,...
...where you take the things that low income households are buying...
...and try to make sure that the iron, the vitamin A, a variety of other things,...
...are included with those foods.
We actually started iodizing our salt in 1998.
In 2002, we started putting vitamin fortification in the sugar, in the flour, in the pasta.
And now whatever that we produce in the Dangote group,...
...whatever you eat, you have micronutrients there.
Here we've got flour that's got the vitamin A in it.
Here we've got salt with iodine in it.
What we just want is for the government regulatory agencies to make sure that, yes,...
...it is enforced everywhere, and that can really help...
...in terms of stopping malnutrition in Nigeria.
By solving problems in Nigeria, you can have a huge impact on all of Africa.